[Música]
expectativa en chile por los resultados
del plebiscito del próximo domingo en el
que los ciudadanos decidirán si aprueban
o rechazan la nueva constitución antes
de que entra en vigor el silencio
electoral las encuestas muestran que los
chilenos se inclinan a decir no al nuevo
texto
a 20 días de haber asumido el poder el
presidente colombiano gustavo petro
sigue recorriendo las zonas rurales del
país este viernes visitó el catatumbo
donde propuso a los cocaleros una
transición hacia una economía legal
en mexico por primera vez la comisión de
la verdad vinculó directamente al
ejército con la desaparición de los 43
estudiantes de ayotzinapa familiares de
las víctimas salieron a las calles de
ciudad de mexico en una multitudinaria
manifestación para exigir justicia por
sus seres queridos
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en france 24 los
saluda andrés meza muñoz el 4 de
septiembre chile vota el plebiscito que
definirá si se aprueba o no la nueva
constitución del país una que
reemplazaría la carta magna heredada de
la dictadura de augusto pinochet tras
apoyar la redacción de una nueva carta
en 2020 el futuro del texto sigue siendo
incierto debido a una recia oposición de
algunos sectores de la sociedad
el estado plurinacional la coexistencia
de diversas naciones y pueblos en el
marco de la unidad del estado todos
estos tendrían el derecho a la autonomía
pero reitera que en ningún caso el
ejercicio de ésta podrá atentar en
contra el carácter único e indivisible
del estado de chile ni permitirá la
secesión territorial la democracia
paritaria 50 por ciento de todos los
órganos del estado tendrán que ser
ocupadas por mujeres según el artículo 6
del documento esto aplicaría incluso
para las empresas públicas además el
estado debería promover adoptar medidas
para alcanzar la igualdad de género el
sistema político de 35 a 30 años pasaría
a ser la edad mínima para postularse a
la presidencia un cargo para el que el
nuevo texto permite una reelección
consecutiva y no alternada como en la
actualidad
uno de los puntos inéditos es la
eliminación del senado de la república
este sería reemplazado por la cámara de
las regiones que estaría conformada por
al menos tres representantes de cada una
de las regiones del país así el poder
legislativo chileno pasaría de tener un
congreso nacional compuesto de la cámara
de diputados y el senado a tener un
congreso para la formulación de leyes y
una cámara de las regiones destinada a
revisar ciertas de las normas
derechos humanos la nueva carta magna
establece a chivas como estado social y
democrático de derecho con el deber de
proveer bienes y servicios para asegurar
los derechos de las personas resalta lo
expuesto con respecto a la educación la
define de carácter laico y gratuito
mientras que lo estipulado para los
derechos reproductivos ha generado
controversia se establece que deben ser
garantizadas las condiciones para un
embarazo una interrupción voluntaria del
mismo así como partos y paternidad
voluntarios y protegidos
en colombia a 20 días de haber asumido
el poder el presidente gustavo petro
sigue visitando las zonas rurales del
país en su búsqueda de la paz total
desde ituango en el departamento de
antioquia el mandatario propuso un cese
multilateral al fuego a los grupos que
habitan en la zona este viernes petro
estuvo en el catatumbo la región con el
mayor número de cultivos de coca en el
mundo e invitó a los campesinos
cocaleros a discutir con el gobierno
sobre una transición a una economía
legal de aurel nos amplía
en este importante lugar para el cultivo
de coca en colombia al presidente
gustavo petro hizo una propuesta clave
me parece una idea sugerente
interesante que se realice en el
catatumbo la primera asamblea de
campesinos cultivadores de hoja de coca
lograr que una familia campesina que hoy
se dedique a la hoja de coca y a la
pasta pueda sustituir eso por una
actividad que le garantice más calidad
de vida más intensidad la posibilidad de
sacar adelante a sus hijos ya sus nietos
el catatumbo es la región con más
hectáreas de coca sembradas del mundo 40
mil según el último conteo de la 1 en
2020 este encuentro sería entonces el
primer paso hacia la sustitución
definitiva y propositiva de cultivos y
producción de pasta de coca así como la
consecución de la paz en un territorio
marcado por la violencia
una propuesta que sigue la voluntad
declarada de gustavo petro de cambiar el
enfoque punitivo hacia los sembradores
del producto base de la cocaína a
quienes considera víctimas bueno lo que
se puede lograr es que se pueda
implementar realmente y de menor a mayor
escala es decir municipal departamental
y nacional el programa nacional integral
de restitución de cultivos ilícitos que
los campesinos cultivadores de coca
puedan encontrar finalmente un cambio
claro eficiente y sostenible en la
sustitución de cultivos ilícitos es
decir que se les cumpla todavía no se ha
dado una ficha para esta reunión de
cocaleros colombia sigue siendo el mayor
productor de hoja de coca y de cocaína
en el mundo seguido por perú y bolivia
en mexico la comisión de la verdad
reveló que seis de los 43 estudiantes de
ayotzinapa siguieron vivos días después
de su desaparición antes de que el
coronel josé rodríguez que se
desempeñaba como comandante del batallón
de iguala ordenara su asesinato es la
primera vez que la comisión vincula
directamente al ejército con este hecho
casi 8 años después la rabia de los
familiares de los 43 estudiantes
mexicanos desaparecidos en el estado de
guerrero en septiembre de 2014 sigue
intacta ahora una semana después de que
la comisión de la verdad del país
revelara que la desaparición fue un
crimen de estado los manifestantes
claman más respuestas coraje e
impotencia de que hayan pasado tantos
años y nos hayan mantenido con muy poca
información y la poca información que
había pues eran mentiras el viernes la
comisión de la verdad hizo una nueva
revelación el nombre de un militar
vinculado con el asesinato de seis de
los alumnos de iguala se presume que
seis de los estudiantes se mantuvieron
con vida hasta cuatro días después de
los hechos y que fueron ultimados y
desaparecidos por órdenes del coronel
presuntamente el entonces coronel josé
rodríguez pérez
previamente la comisión desmintió la
llamada verdad histórica del gobierno
del ex presidente enrique peña nieto- lo
que llevó a que jesús murillo karam
quien se desempeñaba como procurador
general del país en el momento de la
desaparición fuera
la verdad histórica culpaba al cartel
guerreros unidos de la desaparición de
acuerdo a esta los criminales habían
secuestrado y asesinado a los 43
estudiantes e incendiaron sus cuerpos
sus conclusiones fueron siempre
rechazadas por las familias de las
víctimas y desmentidas por expertos
internacionales de la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos
además de murillo karam las autoridades
mexicanas emitieron 83 órdenes de
detención contra soldados policías
funcionarios locales y miembros de
bandas criminales aunque se han
recuperado fragmentos de los huesos
incinerados que coinciden con tres de
los estudiantes los cuerpos de la
mayoría de las víctimas siguen
desaparecidos y seguimos en méxico
porque en 2021 este país ocupó el
segundo lugar con el mayor flujo de
turistas en el mundo según la
organización mundial del turismo parte
de las más de 35 millones de personas
que visitaron la nación azteca lo
hicieron impulsadas por los destinos
espirituales donde pueden desconectarse
de la realidad informe de juan pabló
cumming
llegan a méxico en busca de una conexión
con su alma el objetivo escapar de una
realidad mediada por una inflación
generalizada guerras pero también la
degradación del planeta una frágil salud
mental luego de las secuelas de la
pandemia el destino tepoztlán a una hora
de la capital mexicana en donde cientos
de visitantes dejan el caos de las
grandes metrópolis para conectar con los
sonidos de la naturaleza
aquí me encanta la vibra que la gente
está más relajado y si como dicen más
espiritual y no toma tantos
preocupaciones sobre el mundo que está
alrededor que vive celebrando el día de
hoy muy cerca de las pirámides mayas de
palenque
visitantes entran a una cámara de sudor
calentada por piedras ardientes buscando
un encuentro interior al sonar de la
pandereta
con esta práctica prehispánica
denominada temascal es una herencia de
los pueblos originarios
el ritual consiste en un baño de vapor
con hierbas aromáticas y según quienes
lo practican logra despertar niveles del
espíritu y el alma que han estado
dormidos si desde la pandemia llegó
mucha gente a tepoztlán extranjeros que
se vinieron a vivir aquí gente de la
ciudad que se dieron cuenta que las
ciudades van a bloquear un poco ahí la
energía y aquí está el aire el agua y
viento las montañas los pájaros que es
un momento de regresar a la naturaleza
de cuidar a la naturaleza
pero méxico no sólo atrae a gente en
búsqueda mística el país maya es foco de
turismo que representa el 71 por ciento
del producto interno bruto en 2021 fue
el segundo país con más flujo de
viajeros después de francia según los
datos de la organización mundial del
turismo
el papá francisco número 20 nuevos
cardenales en su octava reunión del
colegio cardenalicio y cuatro de ellos
son latinoamericanos en la nueva lista
de purpurados se encuentran el arzobispo
de manaus leonardo ulrich que será el
primer cardenal de la región amazónica
el de brasilia paulo césar acosta el
arzobispo de asunción adalberto martínez
flórez que se convertirá en el primer
cardenal paraguayo y el arzobispo
emérito de cartagena en colombia jorge
enrique jiménez carvajal
hasta aquí es informativo gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]